شجره عيد الميلاد مضاءه في مدينه غزه
مظاهر الفرح مبهجه والاحتفالات يشارك فيها
المسيحيون والمسلمون على حد سواء لكن فرحه
العيد تبقى منقوصه للمسيحيين في القطاع
فالسلطات الاسرائيليه تحرم العديده من
الاسر من فرصه نادره لمغادره القطاع
والسفر معا في ان التصاريح التي تصدرها لا
تمنح دائما لجميع افراد الاسره تقول وحده
تنسيق الاعمال التابعه للحكومه
الاسرائيليه ان السلطات الاسرائيليه وافقت
هذا العام على سفر ما يقرب من 600 مسيحيين
فلسطيني من غزه وتدعي ان رفضها نحو 200
طلب من مسيحيين هذا العام يعود لاسباب
امنيه
يعني اذا العائله اخذت الاب والام اخذ
تصريح والاولاد لم ياخذوا تصريح يعني ان
لا يوجد احتفاليه ولا يوجد لا يوجد سفر
ولا يوجد امكانيه ان يذهبوا الى الجانب
الاخر والعكس اذا الابناء اخذوا التصريح
الاباء لا يغدروا ان يذهبوا والابناء لا
يقدر ان يذهبوا فبالتالي جميع العائله لا
تقدر ان تذهب الى الصلاه او لمقابله اهلها
في الضفه الغربيه هذه هي المعاناه
الموجوده
بيت لحم سوات 90 دقيقه بالسياره لكن منع
مسيحي غزه من السفر يحول دون لقائهم
باقاربهم واصدقائهم في الضفه الغربيه
ليعيشوا اجواء عيد الميلاد جانب اخر من
جوانب معاناه سكان قطاع غزه
المحاصرين منذ سنوات